Eddie I wanted to talk about that draft
over in Tennessee Nashville Tennessee it
was the most incredible thing I have
seen in a long time and I love to say I
measure people in distance travel daddy
and I'm talking about the draft that I
used to do in New York and the draft I
just did in Nashville that was
incredible man what were your thoughts
when you saw them oh man like I've seen
a lot of different things been to a lot
of events around the country Super Bowls
Pro Bowls I've been in New York for the
draft and I have to say the city that I
live in right now I'm super proud of
Nashville Tennessee got a bid they got
the big prize late about last time like
2018 was a longshot to get the draft
some of the officials from NFL came down
to see how we would handle an event of
this magnitude so how we did the Stanley
Cup Playoffs and how he handled the
crowd when the prevalent every one three
years ago and man I tell you what to see
you see of people from the stage from
where we were standing Mike out to see
almost eight blocks cover the people
both on the streets and on the rooftops
people having a good time partying
celebrating our great game it was
amazing to me is they were all there to
see the draft
yes you guys come across the stage but
I'm really proud of the city we had a
beautifully man it was awesome I've been
asked a few times on appearances I had
to shoot a commercial one time in
Nashville and and I'm not going I'm not
gonna lie to you I didn't know there was
six hundred thousand people in Nashville
at least that was six hundred thousand
people out for that week and I'm like
where did all these people come from it
was it was it was a beautiful man like
you talking about I I did try to want to
stand on that stand on that stage and
look at the sea of people that was that
was incredible I mean I wish everybody
could have just laid their eyes
and in that moment it was incredible
yeah man in the love you know was a love
that was amongst guys like yourself the
Hall of Famers beyond yourself seen a
few other guys Marcus Allen Tim Brown
and in the fans from all over the world
not just around the country all over the
world people from London Germany France
all to celebrate this time here in
Nashville Tennessee you know this the
best kept secret I think in the country
people come here all the time Mike from
Thursday to Sunday to party down on
Broadway and the NFL didn't magnificent
job of laying the grass stage and and
really showing that these rookies and
everybody else a this is how we do it
it's the NFL gonna have a good time
going to celebrate our great game and
these young men coming into the NFL this
upcoming year so was fantastic it really
was and I don't know figure I don't know
if you know Pete I am butchered his last
name a pinaki you pronounce his last
name he's Roger Goodell is right-hand
man and we were talking about it we were
saying every year we should send a
postcard to Radio City Music Hall and
tell them thank you because they because
drafts on the move now because they had
an Easter play I don't know how many
people know about this there needs to
play that they could not move and they
said no they can't give you those days
and so the NFL decided to take it on the
road and this is what has become of it
so we need to send those guys or thank
you each and every year for having that
Easter play you know what I'm saying I
want to talk to you about a couple of
things also Eddie I want to talk to you
about your thoughts on on what young
running back you saw the first running
back was taking was with Jacob Scott out
of Alabama by by the Raiders what ran
back did you see in this draft that you
think will make an instant impact in the
NFL wow that's a really good question I
liked I like the kid that went to
Oakland I tell you an intriguing guy
that plays running back but now is
playing a slot receiver who can do a lot
for you
is jalen hurd kid played a Tennessee
running back there and with the baler
last year I believe I can't remember we
got drafted but he's going to be a great
fit for anybody because now it becomes a
massive problem in the slot in the
middle of fields a big kid six for about
250 pounds for one of four or four and
then you can line up their running back
so he's an intriguing pick for me at
that position but overall you know you
got some guys Singletary Devin
Singletary out of a Florida Atlantic is
also good running back you know a little
of a small side but he runs like a big
guy in between the tackles the kid out
of temple also the good kids to keep
your eye on as well so you just never
know Mike in terms of you know which
running backs going to come to the
forefront because you can get you can
pick up anybody and lit in the later
rounds so we'll have to wait and see
yeah and every year you get a running
back coming in the lead you know that
that's tearing it up and doing great
things and really propelling his team
you know watch Kevin Harvick more couple
years ago just propels his team into the
next stratosphere you know and every
year don't we see that Eddy every year
we're still devaluing the running back
position people are talking about all
you're gonna win with this run about all
you're gonna win with any group of
running backs and things like how does
that make a guy like you feel and what
are your thoughts when you hear stuff
like that
it's disgraceful it's disgraceful
Michael you know it I mean you played
the game you need a wide receiver and it
would be tough for you to have three
reigns without number 22
all right he was the heart and soul at
office he made it go it opened up the
passing attack and if they're gonna win
a championship you've got to have a
running back to do it I mean not just a
tandem you got to have a bell horse
running back who controlled it and
November December and January and get it
done so you know this nonsense of having
three running backs by committee and
trying to get cute bring a guy in on
screens another guy in between the
tackles I mean it doesn't set anything
up but really try to gear toward the
passing game now you got to have that
guy that special garlic in Ezekiel le
like a Todd Gurley like a the other kid
in the world as you just mentioned
Kimora you got to have somebody that's
going to be a game changer that can
change the course of a game and control
the clock when the weather isn't right
so it really upsets me when they try to
devalue the running running game you
also you have lay beyond L up and the
Jets so you know I think it all comes
back to it'll come back to the running
game eventually Mike but I think we're
all enamored with the numbers that these
quarterbacks are putting up when they
own a yearly basis at this point yeah
the rules are made for photos officer
guys it's my core but I'm sitting in for
Rich Eisen on the Rich Eisen show and
I'm speaking with an NFL Hall of Famer
Eddie George and Eddie's sharing with us
about how beautiful that giraffe was in
his hometown of Nashville Tennessee
but Eddie you also are an Ohio State
Buckeye your Buckeye through-and-through
you know I love I love when I'm in that
area when we go down to kin for for the
Hall of Fame and and and I was with
Chris Carter and we were in the restroom
using the restroom at the time and there
was a whole bunch of men and all you got
to do is just you're like yeah o H
everybody in the bar
I mean we're all sooner and still
yelling I oh that just tripped me out
that was funny to me and but let me ask
this though as you watch your
quarterback from Ohio State doing asking
gets passed up by the New York Giants
what were your thoughts on that and what
are your thoughts on what he could do in
Washington I I was shocked I was shocked
I I mean I know carla marie was you know
you gotta pick up a lot Menem toward the
beginning of the draft it seems to the
go number one so I wasn't shocked at
that but when the your pass on to Wayne
Haskins
I was I was really perplexed by the fire
behind the fact that here's a kid that's
the most prolific passer in our schools
history in the Big Ten's history 50
touchdown only eight interceptions
against elite competition week in and
week out we've seen what he can do
I was really shocked that the Giants
passed up on but when the with the
Redskins picked him up and his response
was still messed up now he's hungry
to show the world what he can do I felt
that he slaved in the Heisman in terms
of votes I think the right guy wanted
but I think he deserved more love I felt
like he got slighted during the draft
process as well you know so I think he's
going to come in hungry he's gonna come
and focus he's a strong family support
here Shawn Springs who's his mentor the
cornerback from Ohio State who was with
them during his high school years so he
has a strong pedigree when it comes to
football knowledge and the kid doesn't
get in trouble so for him to come in
with a chip on his shoulder now Michael
he's going to set the league on fire you
get the right weapons around this kid I
think you were lined up for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app